Oh
One. there are four types of introverts social thinking anxious and restrained
Social introversion is what's commonly accepted and understood as the stereotypical definition of introversion
social introverts prefer solitude or small groups of people over large gatherings
They rather stay home with a book or laptop or hang out with close friends, then go to parties with many unfamiliar faces
Social introversion is different however from shyness because there's no anxiety attached to their need for solitude
Thinking introversion is a newer concept
Thinking introverts are introspective thoughtful and self reflective unlike social introverts
They don't feel a need to avoid large social scenes instead they like to daydream using their rich imaginations and creative capacities
Anxious introverts on the other hand seek time alone because they feel awkward and self-conscious
Unlike social introverts they experience painful shyness around new people and the anxiety doesn't
Necessarily go away when they're alone because they let situations play over and over in their heads
Contemplating what might have gone wrong?
Lastly restrain introverts function on a slower pace and prefer to think before they speak or act
They're also known for being reserved. They like to take their time
preventing impulse from affecting their decision-making
Two introverts react quickly to new information, but are slow to monitor change
Introverts brains become more excited when they analyze what steps they must take in the future
But hesitate when they need to prepare for action whereas
Extroverts need to minimize the thoughts in their heads to make a decision but act quickly afterwards
Three introverts dread small talk
Introverts might seem disinterested in other people because they dislike small talk however
They only dislike it because he creates barriers between them and others
Instead introverts want to feel authentically connected, so they crave deep meaningful conversations that help lower social walls
For introverts need alone time
This is because introverts respond differently to rewards such as food money sex and social status than extroverts do
Although they do care about eating income and relationships, they're less driven about and experience less enthusiasm for the possibilities of them
Extroverts in contrast are more excited to work for those rewards, which is why they're so prone to instant gratification
more often than introverts
Five introverts are more careful and calculated about what risks to take?
This is due to a difference in dopamine activity between introverts and extroverts brains
Dopamine is a neurotransmitter
Associated with sensation-seeking risks and new adventures both introverts and extroverts have the same amount of it
But introverts brains are less active in the region that generates dopamine
Six introverts are deep thinkers
Since it reverts use less activity from dopamine. They rely more on a neurotransmitter called acetylcholine
Like dopamine it's linked to pleasure
But the pleasure is produced from turning inwards
This allows introverts to reflect deeply and stay focused on a single task for an extended period of time
acetylcholine also influences them to prefer calm quiet settings over loud crowded places
Seven introverts are more creative
introverts need solitude to recharge
But it's also within solitude where they find creativity
Most artists and writers who identify as introverts produce their best work when they're by themselves as opposed to in group settings
additionally people in general feel less self-conscious when they're alone
So being in solitude helps introverts feel safe to take risks that allow their creative juices to flow
Eight
introverts like the rain
Rain creates white noise that attracts introverts because it signals opportunities for solitude
They find the calming effect pleasurable since it allows them to escape within themselves for the time being
Rain helps lower expectations for the day as well and isn't as overstimulating as the Sun
Nine pretending to be extroverted can have a negative effect on an introverts performance
The time introverts spend on pretending to be people they're not disrupts. Their usual level of performance
It's important to realize and acknowledge this since the world is so used to trying to mould introverts and extroverts
Ten
introverts might not prioritize happiness
Although we live in a culture that emphasizes happiness
Introverts actually prefer to maintain a neutral emotional state when presented with tasks such as taking a test
Giving a speech or thinking rationally. This is because happiness and arousing emotion may distract them from completing their tasks efficiently
Extroverts on the other hand prefer happiness because it acts as a motivator
Are you an introvert if so do you find any of these facts relevant feel free to share in the comments below if
You enjoyed this video
Be sure to check out our website and other social media as well as our new patreon account for more content and don't forget to
subscribe
Thanks for watching